now here's another story to tell you
about residents evacuated from their
homes after a burst water main flooded a
Street in North London early this
morning live to the scene at our
correspondent Emma birchley who's in
Camden goodness Emma what's happening
yeah imagine there's a 42 inch water
main has birthed so it's more than a
meter in diameter and if I step out of
the way you can have a look you'll see
the water gushing up in the street there
by the bollards that's the point at
which the water is coming out onto the
road it's pushed up loads of rubble and
it's gushing down that hill and we
understand that a hundred homes have
been affected people have had to be
rescued people have been moved up onto
the first floor but some people three
adults and a child have been taken to a
rest center and they've been taken there
um in rigid inflatable boats so little
uh boats brought here by the fire
service 60 firefighters eight fire
engines and also those two specialist
teams that deal with flooding like this
I'm joined Now by station Commander Gary
Deacon from the Kent Road and Peckham
fire station hello thank you for joining
us tell us what's the latest of what's
Happening morning so the London fire
brigade were called here this morning
about 20 past three as you said we've
got eight fire engines and two fire risk
units which contain our specially trains
level 2 water rescue technique
technicians we also do have a high
volume pump in attendance and that is
pumping away approximately been around
about 300 33 and a half thousand liters
of water per minute
there's a lot of water there isn't there
there is and as you quite already say
approximately about 100 properties have
been affected by the flood water here
today
the crews have assisted approximately 20
members of the public from their ground
floor basement up onto the first level
and as you say with our colleagues we've
set up a rest center up at the Swiss
Swiss Cottage Sports Center as you said
three adults and a child have been taken
up there and I would encourage that
anybody else in the immediate area
that's been affected by this incident to
make them make their way there um how
deep is the water down there because
quite clearly it's still gushing up and
then right down the road well as I say
it varies in in height I believe that at
the height of the incident it was around
chest height that's what part of the
reason why we have got our Swift rescue
technicians here that are fully kitted
up in their dry suits all right thank
you so much for joining us so 1900 homes
we know have no water at all and
actually there are further homes that
are being affected and it may be some
time before their supply is back in
Action so causing an enormous amount of
disruption you can only imagine what
it's like for those people in those
homes that are flooded just before
Christmas